hay una gran cantidad de tamaños,
formas y colores.
La pluma es una de las tecnologías más asombrosas
creada por el mundo natural,
y por siglos, esta pluma ha ayudado a las aves a estar secas,
mantenerse calientes y poder volar.
Solo una sección del árbol de la vida puede crear una pluma.
De todos los animales del mundo,
solo los pájaros pueden crear algo
como lo que tengo aquí.
Personalmente les he dado un apodo,
y me gusta decirles fabricantes de plumas.
Es la mayor diferencia entre las aves y cualquier otro animal en la tierra,
y si no puedes hacer una pluma, no puedes decir que eres un ave.
(Risas)
Para los humanos, que no podemos volar
los pájaros representan libertad.
Esta pluma ha hecho que las aves conquisten la gravedad
y vuelen de una manera extraordinaria.
¿No quisieran poder volar como un pájaro?
Las aves son mi pasión.
Y quiero cambiar su forma de pensar en cuanto a ellas.
La razón mas obvia por la que las amo es porque son hermosas.
Hay 10 000 especies en el mundo,
y cada una de ellas es hermosa a su manera.
Las aves son asombrosas,
y esta charla está dedicada a todas las aves del mundo.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
De hecho, estas aves han sido parte de nuestras vidas y culturas
por siglos en todo el mundo,
y cada sociedad tiene su historia con las aves.
Seguramente han escuchado historias infantiles de diferentes aves
y cómo se relacionan con el humano.
Hace poco aprendí
que nuestros ancestros seguían bandadas de buitres
y ellos les ayudaban
a ver dónde los carnívoros arrojaban los cadáveres,
y estos humanos buscaban y comían parte de esa carne.
Las aves se han usado como marcas y etiquetas en todo el mundo.
¿Conocen al águila calva?
Fue elegida como el emblema nacional de EE. UU.
por su fuerza majestuosa,
su hermosa apariencia
y su alta expectativa de vida.
Y al igual que los humanos
que han logrado vivir en todos los hábitats de esta tierra,
las aves también han conquistado el mundo.
Desde estos hermosos pingüinos
que viven en estos casquetes de hielo
hasta aves como las alondras,
que viven en los desiertos más tórridos que existen.
Sin duda, estas especies han conquistado este mundo.
Las aves también construyen casas como nosotros.
Los verdaderos profesionales en esto
son un grupo de aves llamados aves tejedoras,
y se les dio este nombre
por la manera en que tejen sus nidos.
Esto es interesante:
a las aves también les gusta tener citas como los humanos.
Les impresionará saber que los machos se visten para impresionar a las hembras.
Y les mostraré cómo.
Aquí tenemos un obispo colilargo.
y así es como ellos se ven normalmente.
Pero cuando llega la época de la reproducción,
todo cambia,
y así es como se ve.
(Murmullos de la audiencia)
¿Si?
A muchas especies de aves
también les gusta tocarse y abrazarse, tal como a los humanos.
Y se que te estás preguntado esto.
Si, también se besan,
algunas veces muy apasionadamente.
(Aplausos)
Algunos han aprendido a engañar a sus cónyuges.
(Risas)
Por ejemplo, la jacana africana:
las hembras se aparean con diferentes machos
y luego se va para buscar otros machos para aparearse,
y deja al macho para cuidar de sus polluelos.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y las aves nos ayudan mucho,
y a diario juegan papeles muy importantes en nuestros ecosistemas.
Los buitres limpian nuestro medioambiente
al digerir patógenos que causan enfermedades,
y se terminan los cadaveres que tanto dinero nos costara
limpiar del medioambiente.
Una considerable bandada de buitres es capaz de dejar un cadáver
del tamaño de una cebra completamente limpio.
en tan solo 30 minutos.
Los búhos ayudan a eliminar los roedores del medioambiente
y esto es de gran ayuda porque nos ahorra dinero --
no perdemos nuestros cultivos --
y en segundo lugar, no tenemos que comprar productos nocivos
para lidiar con estos roedores.
Las hermosas suimangas que vemos en nuestro medioambiente
son parte del equipo de polinización de la naturaleza,
y ayudan a que nuestras plantas den frutos.
Junto con otros polinizadores como insectos,
nos han ayudado
a obtener los alimentos de los que hemos dependido durante muchos años.
Desafortunadamente, la historia de las aves no es perfecta.
Se enfrentan a numerosos desafíos todos los días, donde sea que vivan.
Las mayores amenazas que enfrentas las aves
son la pérdida de su hábitat
y la poca disponibilidad de comida.
Las aves también son cazadas, especialmente las especies migratorias
y patos que se juntan en en agua.
Muchas aves que se mantienen juntas se están envenenando,
especialmente en plantaciones de arroz.
Ademas, las líneas eléctricas electrocutan las aves
y los parques eólicos las despedazan
cuando vuelan a través de las cuchillas.
Hemos escuchado hablar sobre el cambio climático
que ha generado muchos titulares
y también está afectando a las aves,
porque se ven forzadas a emigrar de sus lugares de cría a campos de alimentación
porque desafortunadamente los lugares donde solían vivir
ya no son habitables.
Mi propia perspectiva hacia las aves cambió
de pequeño cuando estaba en bachillerato,
y vi que un chico golpeó
y lastimó el ala y la pata de una ave llamada busardo augur.
Yo estaba para allí,
un chico de 14 años,
e imaginé un ser humano en una situación similar,
porque esta ave no pudo ayudarse a ella misma.
Así que yo, que todavía no era un biólogo en aquel entonces,
junté a tres de mis amigos y decidimos alojar al pájaro
hasta que recuperara su fuerza para ser libre.
Curiosamente, aceptó comer carne de la cocina de nuestra escuela,
y cazamos termitas alrededor del recinto para su cena todos los días.
En pocos días, había recuperado su fuerza
y la liberamos.
Estábamos tan felices de verla batir sus alas
y volar graciosamente.
Y esa experiencia cambió la forma en que miramos pájaros.
De hecho, creamos una revista,
y la llamamos la Revista Halcón,
en honor del pájaro
que habíamos ayudado dentro de nuestra escuela.
Esas experiencias en la escuela me hicieron el conservacionista que soy.
Y esta pasión por las aves debería ser importante para África
y todos los africanos,
porque de entre todos los continentes,
África alberga algunas de las especies más increíbles
que pueden encontrar en el mundo.
Imaginen llamarse "factura de zapato".
Ese es el nombre de esta ave.
Y países como RD Congo,
Tanzania, Uganda y Kenia
lideran el continente con el mayor número de diversidad
en cuanto a las especies.
Estas aves le dan al continente
el ecosistema que África tanto necesita.
Además, es muy probable
que África encabece el mundo del turismo aviar.
La economía seguro se beneficiará.
Imaginen cuántas comunidades se beneficiarán de los grupos de turistas
visitando sus aldeas solo para ver las aves endémicas
que solo se encuentran en esos pueblos.
¿Cómo podemos ayudar a las aves?
Ahora todos Uds. pueden
convertir su pasión por las aves
en una aportación a su supervivencia continua,
y pueden hacerlo si se interesan en la ciencia ciudadana.
La ciencia ciudadana es una tendencia creciente alrededor del mundo,
y tenemos escenarios donde las personas comparten información
con el resto de la comunidad sobre actualizaciones de tráfico,
alertas de seguridad, etc.
Eso es exactamente lo que aprendimos como observadores de aves,
y pensamos, porque los pájaros se encuentran en todas partes,
Si Uds. y todos en África
nos cuentan de las aves que ven de dónde viven,
dónde estudian o incluso dónde trabajan,
nosotros podríamos crear un mapa de cada especie,
y de allí los científicos podrán
priorizar los esfuerzos de conservación
en los hábitats que más importan.
Tomemos por ejemplo estos dos proyectos:
El banco de datos Africa Raptor (ARDB, por sus siglas en inglés)
que mapea todas las aves de rapiña en el continente de África,
y el Kenya Bird Map,
que mapea casi 1100 especies que viven en mi país, Kenia.
Estos dos proyectos ahora tienen bases de datos en línea
y permiten a las personas enviar datos,
y esto se convierte en sitios web muy interactivos
que podemos usar para tomar decisiones.
Pero cuando comenzamos, hubo un gran desafío.
Recibimos muchas quejas de observadores de aves,
y decían:
"Vivo en un pueblo, y no tengo una computadora.
¿Cómo les digo qué pájaros viven en mi casa
o dónde estudio o trabajo?".
Nos vimos obligados a renovar nuestra estrategia y crear un solución sostenible
Fue fácil.
Nos dimos cuenta de que los teléfonos móbiles
eran cada vez más comunes en África
y la mayoría de regiones tenían acceso a uno.
Así que creamos aplicaciones móviles
que pueden usar en su iPhone o Android,
y las hicimos disponibles
para todos los entusiastas que observan aves.
Creamos BirdLasser que es usado por el Kenya Bird Map,
y también tenemos el African Raptor Observations,
que es usado por el Banco de datos African Raptor
Este fue un gran avance en nuestro trabajo
y nos hizo obtener enormes cantidades de datos
de cada observador de aves en las regiones.
Nos dimos cuenta de que la ciencia ciudadana
es realmente muy poderosa,
ya que la ciencia ciudadana es adaptable.
Y pudimos hacer que muchos observadores de aves
comenzaran a compartir información con nosotros.
Cuando comenzamos,
no sabíamos que las aves podrían ser el camino
a la conservación de otras formas de animales.
Interesantemente, ahora en el Museo Virtual para África,
tenemos mapas para libélulas y caballitos del diablo,
mariposas y polillas,
reptiles, ranas, orquídeas, arañas,
escorpiones, y sí, incluso estamos mapeando setas.
¿Quién podría imaginar mapear setas?
Esto nos mostró que en realidad creamos una comunidad de personas
que se preocupa por la naturaleza en África.
Por este medio los animo a
unirse y promover el valor de las aves
dentro de sus comunidades.
Por favor, solo cuéntenle a sus amigos de las aves,
porque estamos inclinados amar y cuidar lo que conocemos.
Por favor, dediquen unos minutos de su tiempo
cuando estén en el trabajo, en la escuela o quizás en casa,
a, al menos, ver a su alrededor y ver las hermosas aves que hay.
Vengan y únanse a la ciencia ciudadana
y cuéntenos de las aves que encuentran en los lugares que visitan.
Más simple aún,
podrían comprarle a su hijo o su hermano
un par de binoculares
o un libro de aves
y dejarlos apreciar lo bello que son las aves.
Porque quizás un día ellos querrán cuidar
lo que conocen y aman.
Los niños de hecho son nuestro futuro.
Enseñémosles a amar a nuestros fabricantes de plumas,
porque el amor a la aves
puede ayudarnos a apreciar todas las formas de la naturaleza.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.